Conscientious people like they,
they value hard work,
rules,
order reliability,
integrity and structure,
and so their dutiful.
We analyze what predicted military
performance.
For example,
in theU ,
s army overwhelmingly conscientiousness.
That's not surprising,
right?
Because it's a very structured rule,
ordered top down follow procedure sort
of endeavor.
Now the armed forces had problems with
that to some degree because they were
also simultaneously looking for people
who could think independently on their
feet because if you're in a battlefield,
for example,
especially if you're isolated from your
command structure,
there's going to be times when you have
to make extraordinarily difficult
decisions on your own,
but if you're selected primarily for
conscientiousness,
that's not going to be your forte
because if you're a conscientious
person,
what happens is that you enter into a
contract with someone,
even yourself,
and then you carry it out.